la scène s'est déroulée il ya un an ici
même à l'angle de l'avenue de suffren et
du quai branly à deux pas de la tour
eiffel le 3 janvier 2020 cédric joue via
chauffeur livreur en scooter de 42 ans
se voit interpellé par quatre policiers
une interpellation qui dégénère
rapidement accusé de rébellion le père
de famille est cloué au sol avec son
casque sur la tête il fait l'objet d'une
clé d'étranglement qui fracturent son
larynx et l'asphyxient transporté à
l'hôpital il décède deux jours plus tard
j'étouffe ce sont les derniers mots
d'agonie de cédric joue via qu'il répète
à cette reprise des mots qui rappellent
ceux prononcés par georges floyd avant
de mourir lui aussi lors d'une
interpellation policière
le 27 mai dernier à minneapolis
etats-unis
des mots qu'il n'aurait pas été entendu
par les quatre policiers mis en cause
dans l'interpellation de cédric show via
devant l'igpn
en juin dernier ils se sont dit
catastrophé al'écoute de
l'enregistrement de l'arrestation du
livreur on n'entendait rien moi même
j'étais essoufflé il y avait aussi
l'effet tunnel
si on avait entendu la moindre parole on
aurait arrêté ce n'est même pas
discutable entendre à l'igpn la voix de
monsieur chouvier à dire qu'ils
s'étouffent à plusieurs reprises ça a
été un choc très violent
pendant tout l'interpellation j'ai senti
de la résistance
quand il a fallu redresser monsieur chou
via après le menottage j'ai pensé qu'il
simulait un malaise
c'est quelque chose que j'avais déjà
rencontré plusieurs fois et c'est très
répandu tout le comportement de monsieur
chou via faisait penser aussi une
caractéristique d'une rébellion
je ne pouvais pas interpréter qu'il
était en train de s'étouffer les
interrogatoires des quatre policiers mis
en cause se sont soldées par la mise en
examen de trois d'entre eux pour
homicide involontaire
chose qui n'aurait pas été possible sans
la diffusion de vidéos x en croire les
proches de la victime tous notamment
l'affiché le père de cédric joue via
réclament justice ainsi que le retrait
de la loi sécurité globale texte dont
l'article 24 puni d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
damende la diffusion malveillantes
d'image des forces de l'ordre en
intervention
lorsque mon père a subi ce contrôle
routier qui l'a amené à mourir ces
quatre individus
ces quatre policiers n'en retirer tous
les droits de s'exprimer de respirer de
défendre et revendiquer ses droits et
aussi de vivre mais grâce aux vidéos
images on nous à rester un droit le
droit de filmer de s'exprimer et de dire
la vérité de contredire leurs mensonges
pour qu'il n'y ait plus d'impunité et
pour obtenir justice
et finalement quand je vois qu'ils
proposent la loi sécurité globale je me
pose la question c'est qui qu'on défend
c'est qu'ils qu'on veut protéger ni
victime ou ses policiers vous l'aurez
compris un an après les faits un
sentiment d'injustice habite toujours
les proches de cédric joue via